uh power versus force
type in power versus force okay
and then click on images click on images
top left
and then click on
the the one with a bun click on that
right there that's fine make that bigger
okay make that bigger
see if you can make click on it again
hopefully it can get okay fantastic so
so adam this this is the challenge in
america today okay
this book was written by david r hawkins
i don't know how many years ago i read
this 20 years ago so it's got it's been
around for a while maybe 18 years ago
something like that so he talks about
when
we go from power
force to power okay and force is
obviously not a good thing to persuade
people
your power you can persuade people
lowest level of influence is shame
anytime you're coming from a place of
shame you have no
ability to persuade you don't have any
power no you can't do nothing you're
helpless right then it's guilt you feel
guilty i feel guilty about what i did to
her i feel guilty about what i did then
it's apathy okay then it's grief then
it's fear you have a lot of anxiety but
fear is still better than grief apathy
guilt and shame then there's desire so
constant sex constant drugs constant
gambling drinking then it's anger anger
is still better than fear because at
least you're expressing yourself to
people right
then you got pride which is where many
people on the certain sides that don't
want to politically sit and agree with
anybody you get stuck at this level
pride
first level of freedom and leadership is
courage having the courage to entertain
what it would look like maybe i'm not
right maybe i'm willing to entertain
then it's neutrality where let's have a
neutral conversation then it's
willingness i'm willing to be
entertained i'm willing to make this
work i'm willing to have a relationship
with gerard i'm willing for us to like
we'll have a conversation together we're
willing you're willing i'm willing we
can make this thing go places but if
you're not willing and i'm willing
there's no way this thing can work right
then there's acceptance then level 400
is what reason what is reason
reason is what we try to do on this
podcast we try to reason reason is when
i interview somebody and we like to
reason with each other we sit down we
have a conversation favorite
conversations in the world are people
that are willing to reason with you
after reason is love which we love you
so that's the foundation of it then it's
joy peace enlightenment which will never
reach that level of enlightenment just
to kind of give you a score they score
people einstein score like a 499 okay
gandhi and them they'll put them at a
different level they got mother teresa
is bliss slash slight enlightenment
jesus is obviously a thousand he scores
it all that in that level have you done
a score
have i done my score yeah yeah i've done
my score and robert o'rourke did my
score before i did my score he came up
to me the other day says do you know
what your score is i'm like i don't know
what my score is how did you do your
score anyways there's a way of doing it
the point isn't about where i'm at or
where you're at where anybody's at i
think the challenge is if we're going to
make progress
we have to have the courage to be
neutral and willing to accept certain
things were wrong and others and then
find a way to reason and if we can
figure out a way to love
well then we can make some progress
though
how do you get people to go from to
shift from force into power you know
that's the first stage there because
there's a lot of pride is there a
question you asked how do you draw them
out you can't do so so you can
so i can get this message sure and then
he gerard like somebody gave me this
message because i was i was in a place
of if you look at me here
uh i was probably fear desire anger
pride
that's majority of my life because i
i've just understood this concept like
20 years because i'm 43
probably at 25 26 i'm still in
fear can i really do this i'm still in
desire man i'm still having girls on the
side i'm still partying hardcore anger i
had a temper horrible i still got a
temper but it's more tame than i can
control it then it's pride so the first
time this was presented to me i didn't
want to you know i'm like i don't know
if this totally makes sense what are you
talking about i'm somebody that's and
then i realize no you're not
you're not willing
you're not neutral you only talk to the
people that you agree with you're not
accepting you're not this you're not
that right you're not coming from that
place so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]